[Music]
wait hi
hey Tashi Duncan just going to turn a
whole family into
millionaires should I have a fashion
line a
foundation you're incredible today thank
you I mean it wasn't even like tennis it
was an entirely different
game
hey come hang out with us later want me
come tuck you in no we just keep
[Music]
talking how often does this happen going
after the same girl not as often as You'
think we usually have different types so
you're saying I should be flattered
aren't you everybody's
type come here which one of
[Music]
us CU may be bad but I'm perfectly good
he's not in love with you what makes you
think I want someone to be in love with
me it's nice to see you lit up about
something even if it's my
girlfriend it's got his coach tshi
Donaldson who also is his wife I'm
playing for both of us
tshi think maybe we disturbed by the
fact that she could have been in someone
like me when we were teenager
when we're teenagers hey I love
you I
know you don't know what tennis
is it's a
relationship we went somewhere really
beautiful together let go I'm taking
such good caream little white
boys I assume you plann this not this
part
CU but I'm perf good I like it like
it hey Doc mhm I was thinking tonight
could be a good night for a sex night
possibly it's an interesting idea but
you know
Thursdays Steven LM how the new Opera
coming along good great great we had
discussed seeing a first draft of the
score in two weeks that still all right
I'm suffering from a temporary blockage
at the
moment no turn it back
on G
flat is he all right he had a total
break on after his last
oper I can't do
this you need to take a walk jolt your
brain out of its little rad pattern
interact with a stranger okay honey I
have a patient
bye are we going that way and keep
imagining you naked I don't know if you
want to hear more details about these
images
no I bet every one of these people has a
story for an opera in them Levi what do
you do they operated a tug boat wrong
hands this tug is a deadly
weapon I'm addicted to romance isn't
everybody I've been arrested for
stalking had to go to rehab and not
supposed to be doing
this can't believe that actually
happened I mean she seduced me right
she's a
witch the demented tugboat captain who L
men to her Tugboat and kills them and
eats them I've loved it how did you come
up with
that I was really angry at you and now
it turns out I'm your amus you what oh
St I'll never leave you
um I love cleaning cleaning is is close
to gness when my patients are talking I
imagine getting inside their heads with
disinfectant and just scrubbing them
down your TG booat Captain came to see
me I'm in Love no no just admit that I
had a magic effect on you my imagination
came up with the story my talent wrote
the music I mean you don't kill men and
eat them do you well I haven't
yet you know I can't resist a romantic
story even if I'm not in
it
that was class sorry that was my fault
are you okay you just had Zach McLaren's
ball in your face what's his
GPA you have any books on battle toads
you know video games are now the leading
cause to divorce Could you actually
order me a book on this really no
sarcasm is frequently an attempt to
deflect one's ignorance so being to know
it all oh wait you forgot your credit
card oh my God what's up the heck get a
card now he has a concussion and he
thinks it him his girlfriend thank God
it's you oh oh all right he is dating
his Zoe what other's Zoe he's either
dead or he's dumb to me honestly I'm not
sure which is worse make sure Zach takes
it easy his symptoms could get worse
what do I do you don't want him getting
worse pretend to be the other Zoe you've
been dating 2 or 3 weeks now
right
y this is Zach's cousin miles he's in
grad school at MIT oh my God a match for
Zoe I'm C accident and now I'm going to
flirt with an Amnesia patient's cousin
we're all going to go skiing in the
mountains this weekend you want to go
with us strip of land seven letters chrm
how did you know that well done you two
should we hit slums H we
shall it's confusing I'm enjoying
getting to know you over again go they a
swing up
life you and Zach do you really think
it's true a good match like we are it's
complicated
we need to tell him the truth you have
to go after what you want and be
brave oh my God you're just giving me
wrong com advice now no it's so
[Music]
fun so what did you do did you have fun
what didn't we do excuse me All PG-13
[Music]
okay
I sent you to the royal wedding with
simple
instructions don't cause an
international incident how's it going
you've done some pretty stupid things in
your day but this Takes the
[Music]
Cake Henry shoved me an urge I currently
share what I need is some good
oldfashioned damage
control the White House and the palace
are going to releas a joint
statement you've got to be joking you
can hate Prince Henry all you want my
NDA is bigger than yours I want you to
know that you're wearing lifts you know
that too sweetheart you better act like
the Sunshine's out of his ass and you
have a vitamin D deficiency I you
thought of what you might say to
convince the world of where Ashley
friends I love hanging out with this
guy we never have to see each other
again you're expected at my New Year's
[Music]
party did I do something wrong do you
ever wonder who you'd be if you were
anous person in the world I have no idea
what you're talking about as thick as it
gets I me yourself your majesty it's
your Royal
Highness dear Alex I miss
you that's what I really want good
morning we are in a hotel crawling with
reporters if anyone sees you leave this
hotel I will brexit your head from your
body your Royal Highness you need to
figure out if you feel forever about him
do you love him what difference would it
make if I did I want someone Prince
Henry belongs to Britain I need we can
figure out a way to love each other on
our own terms it's like there's a rope
attached to my chest and it keeps
pulling me towards
you hopefully we'll get through tonight
without any more
scandals the night is young ma that's
what he
[Music]
want they spent what a trillion
trying to get one dude back from Mars if
you get the opportunity to bring back
Matt Damon I just don't think we should
wait around to be saved you know you
really don't think they're sending
anybody to save us I
[Music]
mean in case you haven't noticed we're
doomed to spend the rest of our
miserable lives on this ship maybe we
should do it do what
it we're not attracted now but we would
emotionally attached you mean fall in
love
what if this awesome thing we have going
on gets ruined people are meant to be
together oh sorry is this is this on
okay
lame we're both married I'm sure being a
drift in space gives you a h
[Music]
pass you know what you want to watch
tonight alien never seen
it why the hell did we watch that mov
[Music]
movie hi what's your name prisilla Boer
you like Elvis
Presley of course who
doesn't what are the kids listening to
these day Bobby Darren Fabian and
[Music]
you just what is the intent here Mr
Presley you got women throwing
themselves at you why my daughter well
SAR I happen to be very fun of your
daughter she's much more mature than her
Age
2 22 that's
[Music]
22 you don't have to worry
about black hair and more eye
makeup I don't know if I like it what do
you mean you don't know if you're ly
yet he's not like you imagined
[Music]
you know there's a lot of rumors about
you is there something you're
hiding I don't have a goddamn thing to
hide I need a woman who understands that
things like this might happen are you
going to be here or
[Music]
not you
want I want a life of my
own I hate the way that I love
you and I need
you I don't want but I want you yeah I
the let's just tell everyone we together
what could be kind of
fun
there's no way we can convince anyone we
actually like each
other trust me we're at a wedding A
Million Miles Away From Home who knows
what could
[Music]
[Applause]
happen convincing enough I hate the way
that
I love you
all I needed was a love you
gave have you guys taken the test yeah 3
years ago we were positive felt like a
weight had been
lifted I founded this institute to take
the risk out of love no more uncertainty
no more wondering if you've chosen the
right partner no more divorce we were
the first to build the machines to
conduct the test to make the bond of
love stronger look from the window
I really want to work
here a lot of famous people study there
really like who Ginger Spice she's my
favorite I
know so you'll be shadowing air he's
already one of our most successful
instructors what's the one thing you
love most about Maria take your time I
love her
hair it's soft it's nice on it's
nice the truth is we're all achingly
lonely and we endlessly searching for
ways to fill that void can I ask you
something why do you work at The
Institute maybe you understand love a
little
better I really want to learn how the
exercises help you connect why are we
doing this I thought it'd be fun it's
just messy that's
all I think it's normal to get into a
bit of a routine I think relationship
should be worked on every day oh sorry
sorry I was wondering if it was possible
that one person could be in love with
two people at the same time it's a
biological impossibility yeah that's
what I thought
too I need to tell you
[Music]
something all I ever
knew only
you
pressure is all right Gary it's
perfect is there any area in particular
you want me to focus on today uh Gary
how many guys have you done this with
you're the first guy that I've ever been
intimate with I had a wife she left I
really don't know what to say I mean
words of affirmation is not my love
language it's more
like
I've been alive for nearly half a
century and I haven't actually lived
even a second of it Gary I'm going to
help you let's find someone for you oh
my God there's so many odd guys I think
that this might just be too much too
late he's already on his way wait
what hello what sup Pro just want to get
in and get out oh you can get in all
right it's a gorgeous Landing what are
you doing I'm calling 911 Gary no
accidents happened it was your first
night being gay did you really think you
were going to make any mistak he
bled through the tar that's Mountain
Ashwood it's really porous oh my God
you're so
gay oh are you a car no wait are you no
good cuz the dark web's built on trust
come
on is this what it's like this is what
it's like I am like human poppers I open
anyone up I'm really glad I met
you even if multiple people are dead
because of it dripping in
diamonds eyes watching Silence as we get
Church girls know how to
kneel where are you
going I am a cool hot zad where'd you
kill him oh we right outside you mov the
body just in the closet you guys ever
seen gong girl just aart with B stick
Gary and never fit in anywhere to
Iranian in America to American in Iran
the only way to survive was to not put
my faith in any of the rules nice
cultural
commentary obviously I've had some
issues with culture can you blame
me what she saying I'm pregnant how can
you be so
irresponsible this is my mom and I's
relationship in a nutshell that really
Hur she's the queen of stubbornness a
trait I'd later go on to perfect oh my
God Elena Hi how are you evidently
better than
you it's time to let go of that anger
I'm trying it's not all my mom's fault I
believe in you but it's so much easier
blaming our mothers how do you say
goodbye
and
everybody we were the All American
Family Trust Me on
[Music]
this this is
Bella Bella this is Mr mandles hello
[Music]
she's an experiment good evening her
brain and her body are not quite
synchronized but she's progressing at an
accelerated
[Music]
paie tell me where did she come from i
s for it is a happy
[Music]
day
I am Bella Baxter and there is a world
to enjoy circumnavigate it is the goal
of all to progress grow a woman plotting
her course to Freedom how
[Music]
delightful
oh yeah to Jane Allstar Baker my best
friend since second grade hero of the
night did you make it J Cut the Cake I
love this cake I love this girl she talk
to more men tonight than she has the
past 23 years combined taking the leaves
thee and I'm harder than a deer on
when you're done channeling with how
sisters get to my
office I thought about this cake thing
you're going to start doing it bringing
cakes into bars one cake a week for a
year and I thought of a name cake
[Music]
barring you got to dig a Little Deeper
bow down bless you like a
pre you because you know I'm bumping you
up to Junior agent can I hug you we have
anything stronger than Aster
Karin I got the results of Karin's MRI
it's not what we were hoping
for if you're at home then your mother
and I can help you stay on top of this
she won't be on her
own I Can Count On You
always okay you're all set up for
acupuncture at 5 thank you can we talk
about pausing cake baring for a second
hi I need
this I just feel like you should be
getting more rest I just want to have
fun and I want you to have fun I wish it
could be about fun as your caregiver
it's oh perfect thank you so much nurse
Caregivers for making sure that
everything sucks all the time I will
wait for
you so that I can
do you are the best you are my
[Music]
everything we're going to look back on
all this as that weird year we spent in
hospitals in
[Music]
[Applause]
Mars sometimes I wish I was you
sometimes I wish I was you you're the
most amazing person I've ever
[Music]
known
hello hi so you're looking at me from
the
[Music]
street I'm assuming you're not with
anyone never see you with
anyone this moment
Dad yeah they died just before I was
12 I'm trying to write about him at a
moment how's it going
strangely
hi
hi is this
real does it feel
real our boys back home our son look at
you you were just a boy and now you're
not it was a long time ago yeah I don't
think that matters maybe I didn't treat
you as good as I should I've always felt
like a stranger in my own
family always scared of
something always running away do you
[Music]
remember sorry I never came in your room
when you were
crying it's funny doesn't take
much to make you feel the way you felt
back there
[Music]
again you think you'd like to be in love
with
him I'd always fall in
love this is a new
feeling you and
me
[Music]
together into the world
I was practically the only non-white
person in my entire high school and you
never felt discriminated again I
definitely did but not because I was
Asian because of your inherent bad
personality
exactly do you remember that internship
that I applied for what about it it's in
New York New York is overrated it's so
gentrified now how many times have you
even been there are we counting
layovers you always assume the worst
about me and then you end up acting
crazy over nothing I'm not acting crazy
so stop using that
word you're just proving my
point are you too like broken up we're
taking some time off while the cat's
away the mous the mouse will play with
himself
probably can I kiss you sorry I'm a
little out of pride yes it's
clear I'm going to go to New York listen
maybe you could come with me I thought
you came out here to clear your head I
did and then I met Meredith and I've
been there ever since so when are you
going to see her I mean I'm here to see
M she's an intern here actually I'm the
only intern
here you have problems with anger
depression your weird self-hatred you
could benefit from a little self-hatred
[Music]
interesting
I know you're going to want to blame
this on society or on your race or
whatever but this really is just about
you this is your rock
[Music]
bottom what is she doing with that guy
they're being
adorable so we finally get to meet your
mysterious boyfriend hello Ben hi Praise
Jesus maybe just be honest with
him is anyone sitting here no
[Music]
H expecting anyone I need to have an
intimate understanding of your marriage
the good and the bad I promise it's
confidential is between you and me do
you feel happy here of course I'm happy
here aren't you do you feel you know how
she would react in every
situation I've always had this fantasy
that there's something else out there
for
[Music]
me do you want to live mundane lives or
do you want to be part of something
special and unique you've been selected
to live up there okay well you're
wasting your time cuz we haven't even
been on an airplane sheated it I should
I should clarify I'm talking about you
here junior
only
[Music]
you we're going to ensure hen has
company while you're
away we're going to replace
[Music]
you I don't want a robot living with my
wife do you really want to leave her
here all alone day after day he doesn't
really see me
anymore maybe I shouldn't be telling you
this
junior I encourage you to use this
opportunity to act on your
instincts whatever we decide we'll be
[Music]
together how yes of course come in nice
place is this the
bathroom this needs to be
cleaned I want want you to clean behind
the
toilet is it dirty yes when you think of
yourself what do you see garbage oh yes
you
weren't I really liked that scene me too
it's going to be so weird to not have
this as part of my routine
anymore what do you
[Music]
mean you know this job Ral of the
company as CEO yeah it's a really big
deal this is not a good idea to keep
doing
this how your new job you wouldn't be
able to do it without what I taught you
what do you want half of the salary for
the job that I got you you're insane it
would be a story CEO material pay this
woman to spit on him and call him her
pervert Denver dominatrix tells all I
mean when you say it like that it makes
it sound
[Music]
weird there's a camera hidden in this
hotel suite I I don't want to play right
now I'm not you filmed our session
secretly where is the camera if you want
to see it so bad then find it you nut
job but if I wanted to I can get rid of
you look at you you love this are you
excited take off your
pants you don't have the power I
do what the what do you want I unlock
something in you no Sanctuary Sanctuary
the safe worth Sanctuary do you even
know why you're doing this or is this
just the game
yes look at me don't look at me
sorry A lot has happened since my big
fat gek wedding like I never W my father
passed away and His Last Wish was for us
to visit his childhood Village and
reconnect with our Roots so we're having
a reunion we're cour to Greece oh yeah 1
2 3 4 and by we I
mean the whole family who wants sui
paging sui anybody by the name of suaki
on this
flight Aristotle what I didn't know you
were going to be here doing here I had
an amazing date she ghosted
him you are the pual family we are
related through your Pap's Papu who was
married to my great great Yaya sister
sister
in I want bua I will be your
favorite I promised my dad I would find
his best friends I know them do they
still live here no how do we find them
they will come for their un did they
tell you they're coming
no there's no other bedrooms family
sleep over this is one
reunion we'll never forget do you know
these men no I am surprised but I am not
surprised because I'm never
surprised you lost me
everybody we dream about Aristotle last
night how did you know great voodo
bam I really need to find my dad's
friends Angel and I on it okay
[Music]
bye I'm calling it you got us back to
Grease You're the head of the family now
I can't really D drink like don't worry
a lady is never
drunk pick the one we for dinner oh
thank you uh I'm a
vegetarian
no we
got come with me come to Spain Spain 10
days all expenses paid get out of town
for a little while okay look no you can
think about
it why are you smiling I just got some
good news about my
trip you must be crazy if you think that
I'm getting these things with you behind
the wheel I don't know how to drive this
is got to be a
nightmare so are you going to tell me
what this Trip's about this trip is
about finding my
mom she's from Spain over the last 2
years I've been doing a lot of research
and I came up with 10 mother
candidates wait that way that way that I
was wondering if you had a
daughter I brown a lot 12 different
homes in my 18 years in the
[Music]
system I just got fed up with all the
unanswered questions what happened to
her what's my family like this is the
only thing I have with
her I got a better
[Music]
idea
look at your mom's signature it says
Maria Aeros what if it said Maria OS and
I just found an
[Music]
address I've died and gone to Venus well
you're certainly not from this
world
is that that guy Robert again listen
concession stand girl why don't you give
me your
[Music]
number wait you never said where he goes
to school I think he just
works oysters come on he has cats his
eyes are nice he crinkle yeah cuz he's
old I think I really like him as
promised I'm not saying I will have sex
with him but I think he would like it
why having this conversation he's a
terrible
kisser listen to me call it a night hey
do we want to do
this this is the worst life decision
I've ever
made I had a good time
tonight didn't you yeah
so what was his go-to move the reverse
squatting cowgirl where his cats Le cute
I never saw them
uh-oh why lie about having
cats cuz liking cats makes a guy seem
non-threatening
harmless he's adding
[Music]
something I'm the monster in your mind
I need to keep someone away from me you
scared me people choose to be
scared can't say I'm surprised to find
lovely ladies like yourselves in here
looking for protection Kelvin you need
to shut that down right
now what is the matter with you you
manipulated
me so he called you a if you want
to get along with a man and not be alone
your whole entire life make peace
well a little
discomfort one of us has to
die I Am The
Monster I don't understand why you have
to formally invite your parents you know
they're coming the invite here I love
that she went with antique Sage is that
the more expensive one our one and only
daughter is getting married do not talk
to me about money right now I still
think they should have
justo Marshall you think I give him a
plus one he's your man of Honor if he's
single he'll come stag otherwise he'll
bring someone but what if he brings
Marie welcome to Tampa lizard you're
getting married can you believe
it
surprise this place is perfect no I I'm
too dignified of a man to be on a beach
I specifically wrote plus one anyone but
Marie James I mean I just don't
understand how someone else can book the
bridal Suite during someone else's
wedding it's me I'm the bride there's a
we can trade no marshmallow no he said
we can have the better room are you that
woman is a disaster I have to do special
brownies for my sister just bake as much
pot in the batter as possible the most
important day of our lives and you were
asked to bring anyone anyone except
Marie God I can't believe you just stole
a trolley what are you doing with my
wedding dress on get this party started
better get
a what did you put in those
brownies
he somebody need a epip pen ow we should
really respect nature no wait on my hand
it's on my
hand get the brid and Grom raise your
glasses to the brid and groom y'all
should
[Music]
be